[Music]
we have distinguished speakers among us
the pond Nancy is a solution architect
for AI and ml in Google Cloud
he joined Google cloud after acting as a
CTO for C's of New York startups in
educational technology AI and speech
recognition his PhD work in computers
has been in computer science at UC San
Diego doing computer vision research at
JPL in machine learning systems group as
an undergrad at MIT in cognitive science
and computer science he worked on a
multi-layer neural network before it was
called deep learning his academic
interests have always centered on the
intersection of cognitive science and
computer science so as you can see I'm
awesome be honored to have you look one
day me everybody for coming tonight it
is an honor to be here at this beat-up
event previous speakers have all been
very distinguished people in the in the
this world of machine learning in Google
and so I'm very honored to be counted
among them so tonight's topic is
optimizing tensorflow models for serving
we're gonna discuss the technical
infrastructure for serving how to serve
tensorflow models on Google cloud in
particular and how even more so to make
that process efficient and make those
models go fast so that we can reduce the
cost of our ml applications and increase
the utilization of the resources that
are required this work is based on a
blog post that was published on medium a
month ago so almost all the information
that I'm talking about tonight is also
on this blog post if you want to go and
read about it there's also
code available for everything that I'm
going to be talking about github in the
Google cloud platform organization under
this project called the TF estimator
tutorials which by the way has a bunch
of other really cool interesting stuff
in it this code is living under in a
subfolder of just one of the sections
there but I would encourage you to check
that repository out and it was also done
in collaboration with Khalid Salama
who's also a Solutions Architect in
Google Cloud focused on machine learning
and so I want to make sure to call him
out here's our agenda we're gonna talk
about goals and metrics for serving that
you know what we are trying to achieve
here is to optimize serving and so we
need some metrics in order to quantify
that optimization we're gonna talk a
little bit about model formats in
tensorflow
there are a lot of model formats and
tensorflow in its short life that's
managed to accumulate several and this
area of serving center flow models
involves you know having some deeper
knowledge about what those model formats
are ultimately to load them using code
and operate on them and so on and
transform them we'll talk about
optimization tools that are useful for
this purpose there are several tools
present in the tensorflow code base that
can be used to optimize tensor flow
models there are also facilities or
tools to optimize center flow that are
built into the tensor flow runtime as
well matter of fact much of what we were
talked about today should be in an ideal
world done by the tensor flow runtime
automatically without you having to
think about it but as we will see that's
not always the case so it is very useful
to understand the kinds of optimizations
that are play here and and how to do
them yourself there are contexts in
which you need to be able to do that we
will talk about the various technical
options for serving tensor flow models
and then finally I'll conclude with
an example of a convolutional neural net
for the M NIST data set that
demonstrates all this stuff again we
should have time for Q&A so I will I
will be happy to take questions during
the talk if you know if you have them
but I also will leave some time at the
end for Q&A
all right let's dive right in so here is
sort of how to frame the problem they
gave it given a tensorflow
training model we would like to optimize
the speed of prediction and we mean for
a single example that you gave to this
model for prediction optimize the time
it takes to perform that prediction and
in general in a broader sense we would
like to optimize the throughput so the
number of examples our inputs per second
that the system that's performing these
serving can process also interested in
in some cases in decreasing model size
model size has an impact in lots of
things in many contexts you care about
the size of your model for example if
you're you know deploying models to the
edge or to mobile devices you would like
those models to be as small as possible
so that they download is fast as
possible it uses a little bandwidth as
possible that they use a smallest memory
footprint on the device there are also
cases where there are actual hard
limitations that you run up against with
respect to model size so for example if
you're using hardware acceleration to
serve your models in many cases the this
is limited by the amount of memory on
the GPU know the acceleration device and
there in cloud machine learning engine
which is one of the methods that we will
talk about later for serving models for
example there's a limit a quota limit
imposed on the model size I think by
default it's something like 512
megabytes for model size now that's not
a hard limit you can make a request and
get that
increased but nonetheless you know it's
something that you may run into you may
your model may end up being too big to
accommodate this whatever serving method
that you're trying to achieve so it's
important to understand like what
factors influence the size of your model
and you know if there's anything to do
about it what you can do about it and
this just kind of replicates what I just
said about model size so as you can see
a eyes does matter when we expect though
the respect to models so we we should be
aware of you know what factors influence
the size of our models and then you know
ultimately what we can do about it and
like I said prediction speed not just
important when we're talking about a
seat serving a single example because in
the end that that's a that's a measure
basically of the complexity of the model
the time that it takes to serve a single
example will be related to the
throughput in the end it's a critical
factor in the throughput and in turn
that throughput is related to the amount
of resources that you're going to use in
order to serve your models which is then
related to the amount of cost that
you're gonna expend to serve models and
relatively small differences in that in
that speed or throughput can have a big
impact in the ROI of your machine
learning application right so if you can
decrease the amount of resources
necessary to serve your models by
something you know not insignificant say
five percent or 10 percent then this
should correspondingly decrease the
amount of cost that it requires to
support your machine learning
application which you know can have a
big impact in the ROI of that
application there's also many cases
where prediction speed is kind of an
essential to the to the application
itself right we you know in cases where
we want to get the result back as fast
as possible because it makes a
difference in the user experience all
right so we care about prediction speed
in general and we want to make it as
fast as possible
fiction throughput like I said is
related to prediction speed but includes
other factors such as Jing horizontal
scaling meaning you know how many you
know
parallel resources are you devoting to
serving and how many examples can you
process in parallel
obviously network performance is going
to have an impact on throughput things
that aren't necessarily related to touch
or flow or to you know machine running
at all compute performance of course
including whether you're using hardware
acceleration or not and a bunch of other
stuff that's sort of beyond our current
scope so today we're really gonna just
focus on how to optimize a
training's tensor flow model as I said
to predict as fast as possible and of
course the other stuff matters but you
know that's beyond our current school so
let's talk a little bit more about the
tensor flow model formats and how they
are implicated in all of this so there
are more than what you see here here I'm
showing two formats the graph depth and
the saved model you probably are
familiar with the saved model if you've
trained tensor flow models because this
is now the most common model format that
you know for example when you train a
model using an estimator and you export
that model it's going to be exported as
a saved model the saved model actually
includes a graph def plus a set of saved
weights basically as files in a folder
structure so saved model is not a single
file it's a folder that contains the
definition of your graph in this graph
def format and in addition some weights
that are in a separate set of files that
are merged together with that graph when
you are low or when you're serving the
model the graph def is a either text or
binary file format that is that uses the
protobuf file format or the part above
data structure format which you probably
are familiar with it's very ubiquitous
across everything that Google does and
so it could be again either in text or
in binary but it based
represents all of the node structure of
your graph right so the tensor flow any
tensor flow model can be expressed as a
graph and the graph def just really
encodes the structure of that graph so
again the same model consists of the
graph def plus a set of weights actually
more accurate to say that the saved
model includes what's called a meta
graph so this is a graph def that
includes some extra information about
what we call the serving signature of
the model which is the inputs and the
outputs of the model so a saved model is
a meta graph plus about a bunch of
weights stored in separate files or
structure this is all very important to
know when we're trying to operate on
these models and try to optimize them
because we have to understand what the
what the underlying data structures are
but we'll talk about several basic
optimization techniques including
freezing the graph pruning the graph
something called constant folding a
operation called folding batch norms and
quantization and there are actually many
other kinds of optimizations that can be
done if you included a few of them here
and you know we're not gonna go into
gory detail about any of these but these
are good ones to know about poor
optimization techniques and as I
mentioned actually there are components
of the tensorflow runtime which we will
talk about that perform many of these
optimizations as well tools that we will
use are really two main ones there's a
grep there's something called a graph
transform tool which has been in the
tensorflow codebase for some time I mean
the world of tensor flow you know eons
like since like 2016 and that in the
blog post and in the examples that I'm
that I'm going to cover is the main tool
that we will use
however there
another tool called grappler that is
present in the tensorflow
runtime that is performing a lot of
these optimizations again for it should
be in a theoretical sense for you
automatically such that you don't have
to think about it
the reality is a little bit different
than that we'll talk more about why that
is the case
yeah the graph transform tool by the way
is a command-line tool but it also has a
Python interface grappler is basically a
component of the tensorflow
runtime that recently also got a command
or a python api associated with it as
well so you can call both of these
things through python code which is what
we will do here but in the case of the
GTT the graph transform tool there's
also just a command line version of that
that you can use so in summary the
optimization process is this we're gonna
take a save model which again is you
know by far the most common format that
you probably are dealing with when you
you've got a trained tensorflow model
that's been exported we're gonna convert
that into a graph death and that that
process is called freezing the model
basically merging the weights of the
that are saved out externally with the
graph such that it now has all contain
in a single file why would we need to do
that before we start optimizing oh the
answer is that if you keep the weight
separately separate from the graph and
you start operating on the graph pruning
it and changing it and optimizing it
then that structure that that existed
before and the weights is no longer
gonna map back to the graph and you
won't be able to overload those weights
back in you might be you know removing
nodes you might be collapsing notes
together and so effectively if you don't
do this you will have a broken model so
really this model freezing step is the
first step in any optimization process
so that we're dealing with you know a
graph that contains all of the weights
kind of merged into the graph as opposed
to stored separately so that then when
we operate on that graph you know again
pruning nodes and merging nodes together
and changing the structure of the graph
that we don't
for now that no longer or you know where
the where the weights and the graph
don't have the same structure once we've
done that once we froze on the model
then we can optimize the model by
basically operating on that graph again
doing all kinds of operations that we'll
talk about to the graph that involve
shrinking the graph size and making the
graph more efficient and you notice is
that it contains fewer operat operations
optimizing it and then once we've done
that we're gonna want to convert that
back to a saved model because in the end
the save model is what is the most
useful model format so if you're gonna
be loading this model into a serving
that's like tensorflow serving or a
cloud machine running engine it's gonna
want to save model not the case that
when you do that you somehow re-export
those weights out to separate files
so that you know a saved model can can
consist of a graph file that has all the
weights merged into it and then just an
empty set of directories that that
contain nothing and tensorflow is fine
with that so but but we still need to
add this meta graph information that I
mentioned back to the graph def to make
it from a you know to convert it from a
graph def into a saved model graph but
we don't need to be export the weights
so the weights will still be merged into
this
it'll still be a single file basically
just in the same a saved model folder
structure that has just this one file in
it that that represents the model so
let's talk a little bit more detail
about freezing the model again this is
basically to you know consists of
merging the weights into the graph
giving you a single file I mentioned
that already I covered that pretty well
so pruney is another optimization
process that we'll talk about that
essentially consists of you know the set
of operations that deuce the size of the
graph either removing extra nodes that
are necessary we call for example
identity nodes meeting notes that act
like the multiplication of one or you
know the basically they're like no op
nodes that don't do anything
to the to the graph or don't do do don't
affect the computation that's being
performed by the graph other things that
you know operations that you might do in
tensor flow like shuffling on a tensor
of size 1 or reduction of dimensions MP
dimensions and things that happen in the
course of model development or you know
in the course of you know operating on
your tensor flow model that the
optimization process can eliminate which
then results in you know a smaller more
efficient graph in addition a lot of the
times when you're developing a graph in
tensor flow through some of the api's
there will be multiple output nodes
created meaning in an output node is
basically a node of the graph that
produces the answer all right and so
it's not always the case that you have
one set of outputs for a tensor flow
graph sometimes you have multiple
outputs but it's almost always the case
that when you're actually using the
graph you only care about one of the
outputs and so when you actually use the
graph in a production context then you
want to make sure that none of those
other output nodes are present in the
graph because that's just extra
computation that the graph is doing that
is not necessary so we want to make sure
that we prove that we remove extra
outputs it's not always the case that
you'll have these extra outputs but
there are some api's that when you use
them produce multiple outputs it's
possible that we need to you know define
your graph however you're doing that
using the high level api that you would
get multiple output nodes and so this is
one of the things that we have to prune
so constant folding is is basically
being constant operations that might be
chained together and just pre pre
computing them using batch norms is
actually similar to this so I I don't
know who's familiar with batch
normalization a few of you but if you're
not familiar with batch normalization I
would say you should be it's a becoming
I would oh it's call it a sort of a a
standard technique that you know may
have been like a research technique a
couple years ago but
by now anybody who's doing you know
serious deep learning should be using
back to norm inside their models in fact
as of I think tensorflow 110 110
they included batch normalization in the
canned estimators tensorflow so it's
actually all built into the you know if
you're gonna specify a deep neural net
using the DNA and estimator classes you
have the option to turn back to normal
on so again it's almost always the case
that you actually want to do batch
normal it's not really time to talk
about that in detail what Bachelor is
but trust me if you're not using it and
you have like a deep neural network or a
convolutional neural that you should be
effectively what it does is normalizes
the activations of each layer as the
layers as those activation values
propagate up through the model by
looking at the statistics of the data
basically that you know starting with
the input data namely the batches of AB
data that are feeding into the model but
even as you go up through the layers
there's a computation that's being done
so that and by normalizing meaning
meaning like you know subtracting away
the mean and centering those those
values this turns out to make learning
much easier and faster and but in the
end you're computing some statistics on
those inputs and on the values of those
activations and those statistics are pre
computed during training they're not
computed during prediction so the
statistics are computed as you know a
mean and a standard deviation during the
training process and then they're
embedded as constant values inside the
network and you can just merge those
constant multiplications that are
happening there into the graph itself
alright so that's a lot of explanation
that what using batch norm is but it
does give us the opportunity to talk
about batch normalization and and what
it is and why you should know about it
yeah
are you going to have to model I guess
the answer to question is yes that that
we are explicitly doing operations to a
model to prepare it for serving and yeah
if you wanted to say do further training
on that model say incremental training
or add more training that yeah you would
not want to have this fused optimized
model instead you would want to start
with a model that would that still had
the the structure of the batch
normalization structure in it so yeah
we're really talking about a process
that we apply to models after they're
trained to prepare them for serving yeah
yeah that's that's right yeah I mean it
you know in other words we're competing
a statistics based upon an X and then
exponentially weighted average of the
previous values and again you know we
don't need to go into gory detail about
what Bosch norm is or how it works but
you should at least you know the concept
should or the name should be familiar to
you I advise you if you don't know what
it is you know learn about it and learn
how you what you should know it or what
you should make sure is that it's it's
on inside your model
hopefully the the the frameworks
certainly Karras will do this for you as
well as some of these canned estimators
but but for those of us that are
building custom models we have to
explicitly include batch norm inside our
model definition ization is a quite a
big topic in and of itself but
essentially refers to taking the weights
inside a model and reducing the
precision so going from a 32 bit way in
some cases a 64 bit weight and reducing
down to a 16 bit or an 8 bit weight this
does reduce the accuracy of the model in
many cases
but not by much and you get a really big
boost in speed and performance by
quantized quantizing and you get a much
much reduced model size as well right
because most of the size of a model is
due to its weights and so if you can
reduce the amount of data that it takes
to store those weights by a factor of
four you get a much much smaller model
the quantization is really implicated in
a lot of what we do with respect to
model optimization these days again at
the time you don't have to really know
about the details of this it's done for
you but there are cases where you really
have to understand quantization and how
to apply it and if you do that you can
get really big boost in performance
certainly in speed but also in the model
size now I had a cost by the way of some
amount of accuracy all right so if
you're gonna apply quantization to your
model actually really this applies to
all of the things that we talk about
here you should test before and after to
make sure that nothing that you did
changes your you know your accuracy or
the you know the the precision of your
results at least not in a way that you
know makes your use case no longer valid
again this is what kind of the
transformation looks like when you're
doing quantization inside a graph you're
taking something that you know is sort
of a simple sequence of floating-point
operations so here we have an input oh
it's the where r lu activation function
is being applied to it that's produces
an output and instead because again
you're you're reducing the precision and
so you need to know what the ranges of
that weight so that you can map it back
so you have to pre-compute
which the system will do for you or the
optimization tools will do for you the
the min and the max then you reduce the
precision you perform the calculation
and then you map it back to the original
floating-point value folks heard about
tensorflow light so this was a system
introduced last year basically to
optimize the deployment of models tensor
flow models on mobile devices one of the
key techniques that
the light is doing to make models work
well and fast on mobile devices is
quantizing down to eight bits so in this
case tension love light actually does
all this quantization for you you don't
have to worry about it but that is the
secret sauce underneath a lot of what
tension flow light is doing is basically
quantizing your model down to a bit a
fair bit about all the various
optimizations let's look at in more
detail at an example we're just going to
talk about a feminist convolutional
neural net which is kind of a standard
neural net that you might deal with and
this is the full optimization process
that we will apply first we will run
predictions so that we you know we know
what the model output before we applied
all of our optimizations and we know how
fast it ran all right so we have to do
that before so we have some kind of
benchmark or baselines so that we know
what affect our optimizations had we
also want to run predictions so that we
can verify as I said which we should all
we do always do at the end that we
didn't break our model or reduce
anything that you know that reduce the
precision of our model or the output
it's quite easy frankly to break your
model by doing this stuff to it and so
you want to make sure that you can
verify that the model at the end of the
process still performs well or at least
you know in an accurate way and then you
also want to be able to quantify the
effect of the optimizations right so you
need to have a baseline benchmark at the
beginning then you freeze the graph you
run the optimizations again we're going
to show this using the graph transform
tool but others also this actually more
advanced and more recent tool called
grappler that can also use we convert
that model back to a save model for map
and then we rerun the predictions to
verify that we didn't break it but it's
still as accurate as we needed to be and
we also benchmark at that point to
quantify the effect of our optimizations
let me just say a few words about
benchmarking methodology there could be
a whole
separate talk on that but it's really
important I think to be careful about
how we benchmark because a careful then
we may you know draw some incorrect
conclusions about what we just did we
may decide that uh these optimizations
didn't work at all because it makes a
prediction longer and so it's important
to have some consistent benchmarking
methodology and to pay attention to to
what we do here you know in and again I
guess I won't go into gory detail about
this but I just want to say that you
know the three desirable attributes of a
benchmark are that it's repeatable
meaning that you get the same answer
when you run it multiple times
oftentimes it's that's you know because
computers are a little bit in
deterministic frankly you know in sort
of varying ways you often won't get
necessarily the same exact result so we
want you know when we say repeatable
we're not necessarily saying we could
get the exact same result but it needs
to be within a small sort of range these
two have the low variance we want to run
the benchmarks in a controlled
environment meaning you have to have a
lot of control about all of the
different components that we're testing
there you know if there's some part of
that component that we don't control say
for example the network right if you're
running a benchmark across from your
laptop across the cloud to to something
that's running in the cloud you know
you've got a big chunk of stuff that you
have no control over there between you
and what you're running and we also want
and make sure the benchmark has a
limited focus meeting is only testing
the things that we're interested in and
not trying to test lots of different
things because again that sort of
reduces the amount of control that we
have by definition you know testing more
things makes it more likely that there's
some part of that system so again that's
all I want to say about that but
influences the choice of how we might
decide to benchmark our model
optimizations because there are multiple
ways that we could do that right so one
of them would be just to use pure Python
it's a very easy thing to do now
particularly with this contrib predictor
module that was added to tensorflow that
allows you to perform predictions in
python now of course this is tensorflow
100 that has the contribute which is
going away migrating it's not going away
right yeah so that's the wrong way to
say it yeah it's migrating to somewhere
else where it will be still useful still
be able to be used anyway that's a
that's a potential method cloud machine
learning engine predicts service very
useful important service which I'll talk
a little bit more about later a very
useful for production prediction right
you know you can train your models on
cloud and machine learning engine and
then you can very easily take that same
model and set up a predict service for
it on the cloud and then another option
would be is TF serving which is another
serving option again I will have to talk
a little bit more about all the various
serving options the later using uh you
know just a rest call so like basically
running an instance of TF serving you
know in a container locally these three
can anybody say which is the best Oh
the answer is TF serving locally the the
Python method suffers from the fact that
Python itself is sort of not a very
controlled environment because it's an
interpreter that is doing a lot of
things under the hood that you have no
control over like garbage collection and
it tends to just to be very in
non-deterministic from run to run if you
try running your code on you know using
Python even if you do you know make it's
more statistically valid by doing bigger
batches or like you know more
predictions you will find that the
results are quite variable I mean this
is you know you could overcome this
right you could run you know the
benchmark ten times and average the
results but you'd rather not have to do
that cloud machine learning engine was
it so as we said you know the the
challenge is to see you running
something in the cloud and you're trying
to test that locally Eva or even if you
were having an instance on the cloud
that's that's making calls out the
machine learning engine to do that
predict there's a lot of stuff there
that you just have no control over and
Ashima engine predict as a managed
service so means it's handling a lot of
the scaling issues for you so in the
middle of your benchmark run it might
you know see that your you know your
load is spiking and try to allocate some
more instances for you to do this
prediction which would then throw your
benchmark results off completely and not
be very repeatable so not a great choice
running TF serving locally in a docker
container is actually quite controlled
and it should be quite consistent from
run to run because and you know again
you're running it on your laptop you've
got a lot of other processes running at
the same time and that could influence
the result but nonetheless of all those
three options it's I would claim the
best and so that's the one that we used
in the blog post again in the code
that's out on github you will see all
three options as examples so you could
you know test each of them out and it's
also just useful to have sample code
that uses the contra predictor to do
predictions you may not even know that
that existed the cloud machine learning
engine you know also useful to have an
example of that and then finally the
deploying and you know using TF serving
in a local container as well is also
useful I'm gonna make a little diversion
here quickly to talk about the various
options for serving tensorflow in a
production environment and we've talked
about five machine learning engine the
predicted service thereof it's a managed
service it's a lot of great features for
doing prediction a very easy transition
from training to predict basically in
your training process you have at the
end of it you export the save model and
then it's very easy to launch a predict
service from that same same model you
can do online predictions and batch
predictions
it contains facilities to do model
versioning it does support other
frameworks then tensorflow now so
scikit-learn and XG boost and I was
asked by the product manager the the
technical lead here to mention that very
soon you'll be able to deploy predict on
any machine type that's available in GCE
so you have a lot of even more control
over the kinds of machines that you're
running on and also to harness GPUs
so really good option for for deploying
your models at doing predictions again
if you're interested in a managed
service meaning you're you don't need to
have like very strong control over the
underlying architecture very good for
for deploying your models to production
that's not so great as a benchmarking
tool necessarily TF serving we talked
about based on a open source component
from the tf-x platform which is Google's
internal platform for machine learning
pipelines which we are now open sourcing
the components of sort of like one after
the other I believe TF I believe the
serving component was the first
component that was open source one of
the nice things about TF serving is that
it has a facility to update the models
dynamically meaning it can be up and
running
serving your you know examples and then
you swap any new model under the hood
and TF serving will automatically pick
that up and just you know seamlessly
transition from the old model to the new
one there's a large community inside
Google and outside Google that's using
TF serving I will say it's if you're
using GPUs it's it is challenging to
harness multiple GPUs using TF serving
it can be done but you have to encode
the device assignments in the graph and
so that's one I would say drawback of GF
serving if you really have engine
throughput requirements for your serving
application and you really need to have
you know running on machines that have
you know for a GP use attached with them
then it's a challenging thing to do with
TF serving the architecture for a
serving system and production sort of
looks like this where you typically
would deploy TF serving inside a
kubernetes cluster where each node has
its own instance of TF serving and then
you have some kind of load balancer in
front that is distributing those serving
requests across the nodes
there's a thing option from our partner
in video called NVIDIA inference server
which includes the capability to harness
some
they called tensor Archy which I'll just
talk about a little more
this basically harnesses some of the
capabilities of the newer the newer
NVIDIA GPUs they have something called a
tensor core unit inside them it's
actually this this tensor core unit that
is used under tents RIT is basically
harnessing quantization so under the
hood its converting your weights into
sixteen bit and it's got hardware
acceleration it's really really fast for
processing these with these weights this
feature is present in the V 100 and the
new P 4 which we just announced publicly
that's available on Google Cloud for
serving it's a few core that's really
specialized to serving so it doesn't
have a lot of onboard memory but it's
really fast and cheap or cheaper than
some of the other options for doing
serving it's also like I said present in
the V 100 ok so back to the optimum the
optimization process talked about
running predictions and and benchmarking
the baseline I think I actually had a
number up there that was like 189
seconds for this particular sort of
amnesty NN kind of simple and this CNN
which is that basically I think a
thousand executions of a batch size of
100 this is what it looks like to freeze
the graph said we're calling this freeze
grasshop graph operation using the
Python API which is present in the
Python tools module under tensorflow
this freeze graph tool can be called
directly here it actually has one of the
largest set of arguments of any method
call that I've seen intensive loads I
didn't put all of them here and so
there's like ten more that are required
like you can't even there 19 optional
but anyway the sample code shows you how
to do this and that the output is
basically a you're providing the output
graph filename and so it actually writes
the output graph the frozen alpha graph
for you when it completes this is what
running the optimizations using the
graph transform tool looks like again
you give it a list of the tech
transforms that you want to run
then you run this transform graph method
and it produces the optimized graph as
the output then you have to actually go
save that graph but again the sample
code shows you how to do all of that and
then finally you want to conserve
convert back to save model this turns
out to be kind of unwieldy and harder
than you'd like it to be but basically
if you know the right API is to call
it's not that bad you use the TF saved
model simple save method and again you
have to provide the inputs and a list of
inputs and the list of outputs that you
want to save and so you have to actually
know that or know what those nodes are
in this example code we found the inputs
by just looking for placeholder nodes
which is essentially or you know
typically what would provide the inputs
to a graph we got the outputs using
actually by looking at the meta graph
death as I talked about like the meta
graph deaf includes the signature that
that gives a list of the output nodes
and so that's where that came from
and then the benchmark again after
applying the set of optimizations and
instead of 189 seconds it takes 162
seconds so that's about a 15%
improvement which is not bad for just
running a few optimizations and it's
actually significant enough that I
wouldn't you know could make a
difference in cost and speed certainly
that a difference that you would care
about you to the optimizations that
would perform should preserve the the
output for a given input in other words
hopefully again this is something we
have to verify but there shouldn't be
anything that we did that would change
the output for a given input actually we
didn't do quantization this one but
sorry yes
so tensor arty actually only makes sense
if you're doing it on DP you in fact
really by definition what it is is
preparing your model so that it will is
able to harness those tensor cores that
are built into the V 100 in the p4 and I
think all of the GPUs going forward from
Nvidia or most of them will will include
this special unit tensor RT is a kind of
a topic in and of itself we talked a
little bit about that there is sample
code out there that shows you how to
apply tensor Artie again it's been
present inside the tensor flow code base
since you know I think March of last
year like as of like 1.7 so it's
reasonably stable but you also need to
use the Nvidia imprint server in order
to harness it having said that if you
really want like really high performing
serving it's pretty much the way to go
I also would say you probably would need
to engage with Nvidia in order to make
it work it's it's complicated to get it
to work we're just about to publish a
actually there's already been a blog
post that shows you how to do this on V
100's just about to publish another blog
post that shows you how to do it using
the P Force so you'll have sample code
out there available if you're interested
in doing this but like I said it's
something that you probably need the
help you probably need end up need some
technical help in order to pull it off
you know over the course of this year
I'm sure the Nvidia and the Nvidia
inferred server will get more stable and
more robust there are some other things
to say about the Nvidia inference server
it's not dynamic actually yet like TF
serving is which is a problem almost
every practical ml application is
dynamic in some sense meaning you know
you don't ever almost never train a
model on static data and then just serve
it you don't kind of ad infinitum
typically you're gonna update that model
based on new data at some point and so
the process of deploying the new model
gets a much more complicated
because you have to you have to have
your own system for like doing this
hot-swap right or you have to be able to
bring the model bring the whole server
down and then you know swap in a new
model and bring it back up or you know
something more complicated where you you
know you migrate traffic over from you
know you deploy a new instance and you
might get it so anyway there's a reason
why ITF serving is dynamic is because
it's actually kind of a pain when the
serving in infrastructure is not dynamic
those other optimizations that we
perform did make a difference right so
we still let's go back this is the list
that we talked about that we were going
to do so these removing kind identity
nodes folding constants merging
duplicate nodes actually it's kind of a
form of pruning or you have you know two
nodes that are in succession that that
do the same operation they're being on
you just nodes meaning any nodes that
are not that are being calculated but
are not actually connected to the output
right so that would include extra output
nodes but also just like uni there are
there oftentimes nodes in your graph
that end up getting added that you're
you know not that don't there's no edge
from that node back to the output and so
those noes get pruned and then there's
folding batch norms which we talked
about as well so those are the that's
the set of transforms that we did so
this is a good topic as actually kind of
leads me to the sort of the conclusion
at the talk which is that the the truth
is that grappler which I mentioned which
is built into the tensor flow runtime is
actually performing all of those
optimizations that we listed and TF
serving which is the serving mechanism
that we used uses grappler but we still
see the results that we see it we see
them consistently across multiple models
we actually implemented this using
vanilla tensorflow and caris and all of
that code sample code is in our repo and
yet we see this performance increase
i've been talking to the folks that both
on the TF serving side and the grappler
side and try to understand why this is
the case but it kind of highlights the
fact that you need to take control of
the you know of your serving if you care
about performance you know you should
not rely airily on everything you know
working perfectly under the hood I mean
you would like to but the reality is is
that for some reason and we're not sure
I'm still not sure why this why grappler
is not performing in the way that it's
supposed to in this context but
nonetheless it's it's very reproducible
for some reason the grappler
optimizations that are supposed to be
happening inside tensorflow serving or
not happening so again in an ideal world
this this set of optimizations for most
cases if you're using TF serving should
not be necessary now there are some
cases where you're doing you know
another kind of serving mechanism that
you can't rely on grappler kicking in
and so this is a good useful knowledge
to have but the also the reality is is
that despite grappler supposed to be
doing performing these optimizations in
the test that we ran it was not and
again we'll figure out why that is you
know as you know tensorflow
is a very rapidly evolving system and
you know things don't always work
perfectly and so you should take control
over your own model process particularly
if it if there could be a 15% difference
in your performance and and
understanding all these processes and
how to test them is important but the
reality is is again I think what at the
set this we discovered this after we
published the post in November that
actually grappler is supposed to be to
applying all these optimizations and
because TF serving uses grappler that it
this these these optimizations shouldn't
work but they do and so some things
wacky again maybe it's something that
we're doing I don't know but you know we
repeated these like I said we did it on
more than just one model we did using
multiple api's and we're it was very
consistent that we saw about this 15%
improvement so I don't have all the
answers here I don't know exactly what's
going on but anyway this was I think
it's still a useful exercise and
understanding you know the details of
the model formats and the optimization
processes and things like quantization
which we didn't do here but can be you
know a really important factor in your
the efficiency of your serving processes
as well okay
so that's that's the end here again
we've had lots of questions that Rick
really great questions during the talk
[Music]
like with that with what we're doing
here change that like right that's a
good question so the whole topic of
explain ability maybe come I'll come
back someday and give a talk about that
I've actually been working on that
myself very very hard but interesting
topic in the world of ml these days
lots of people are interested in it I
mean the short answer is what we're do
what we did here should not change the
mathematical result of the bottle
meaning none of the optimizations that
we did here should change the
mathematical results that are computed
by the graph but again you have to test
that don't believe me right you know
that's why I said run the predictions on
a test set in the in the case of M nest
it's the M NIST data set right and then
run it again and make sure that your
outputs look the same for it for a given
input it's you know this is not that
hard to do there's only 60,000 examples
in the amnesty to set so you should
really verify that the numerical output
for a given input is the same but the
truth is all the optimizations that are
performed here should not have changed
the mathematical calculation that would
be performed by the graph interpretation
is another big topic that we probably
don't have time to talk about much today
but maybe I'll come back and talk about
that later
yeah the absolute value the values of
these benchmarks will definitely change
according to the model and they will
also the absolute values will change
depending on which system you run on but
but the key thing we're looking for is
are they consistent on it for a given
model on a given machine are they
consistent from run to run and the
method that I talked about here today in
empirically is quite consistent ya know
knows this is just a CNN that we created
that's just a few a few layers you know
very simple CNN to do um this yeah my
pleasure no problem of layers or
oh now that's a hard question to answer
yeah but it really depends on this the
what's how the model is constructed and
what operations are being used you know
these these big deep CN NS that they use
to do image recognition again like
ResNet or inception are actually quite
complex from an architectural standpoint
if you look down in in the details of
other constructive which ones are
compressed the most or which ones good
um yeah I couldn't answer that yeah I
haven't done a I haven't actually done a
comparative survey but yeah yeah it
should yes oh no it there's nothing that
we could do here that would make your
model more accurate there are definitely
things we could do that would make it
less yes for a given accuracy I mean
again if you're processing medical
imaging you probably do care about the
throughput in the prediction speed right
because those are very big you know big
images and the models that you're using
probably quite big as well and so it can
make a big difference in the amount of
time that it takes or the costs so I
mean these optimizations make sense
although like again theoretically you
shouldn't have to perform them and in
many cases yeah yeah I mean we're
actually not here concerned with
optimizing accuracy that's that's
the realm of training you know like
that's the whole you know the whole
world of making your models as accurate
as possible as this world of training
which you know people talk about a lot
right I mean they talk about how to
optimize training and how to distribute
training and how to make training go
fast you don't see as many people
talking about optimized serving that was
one of the motivations that we had for
doing this work yeah thank you yes there
are coding changes but hopefully not to
to evasive yeah not too extensive if
you're using the estimator if you are
then it's actually pretty minimal and I
don't know about Kerris yet with respect
to GPUs is it that's right yeah I'd say
that I couldn't ever believe how we
would expose to the outside world
there's a TPU all right for free yeah I
know somehow we managed to do that but
yeah yeah you'd figure some Bitcoin
miners would have figured out how to
take advantage of that somehow but yeah
yeah so if you go look in the
documentation for this graph transform
tool there are actually lots of
parameters and ways that you can adjust
or you know Optim ops optional
transforms that you could perform that
you know maybe more aggressive you know
at the time to talk about all that here
but yeah I mean there are there are some
you know more experimental transforms as
well that can be performed that have you
know a greater likelihood of changing
your results or potentially not working
with your graph so yeah
this world of transforms is actually
deep and rich when you when you dig into
it and again you know hopefully most of
the time in most contexts you wouldn't
have to know all this stuff because the
tents are close on time is doing it for
you but you know as we saw here you know
it's it's useful to know because maybe
something went wrong and the tentacle
runtime isn't working correctly or TF
serving is not working correctly and
it's or that you maybe not be using you
may not be using ts serving like maybe
you know I have the applications here in
IOT where people are running predictions
on an edge device or even like a
Raspberry Pi where there's you're not
going to be able to get TS serving on
that device and so it's good to know how
to do this kind of stuff also just to
understand better for example what
frameworks like TF light tentacle light
are doing under the hood to optimize
your graphs so yeah it's a very very
interesting deep world most of which is
happening kind of under the hood and you
know you don't hear about it but we're
hoping to expose some of this
information to the public it's part of
this
[Applause]
[Music]
you